welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and I am NOT okay
with this is a show that has just
dropped on Netflix throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the new
season it's ending and where things
could be going we're also gonna be
giving our thoughts on the series and if
you haven't seen it why you should check
it out there will be heavy spoilers here
itself you haven't had a chance to watch
the show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now which she subscribe to the
channel to never miss video as we do
break downs like this every day anyway
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of I'm not
okay with this what's he doing right hey
I am NOT okay with this opens with the
callback to Carrie and the show actually
centers around the lead-up to a similar
sort pot point as the finale of that
film without being a big outburst at a
prom the show jumps back and forth
between the build-up to this and the
aftermath of it making for a mystery
that drives a lot of the season it's not
the most original premise but it's rare
that we see a coming-of-age story set at
a high school that's mixed with a
superhero origin okay I'm kidding it's
been done a lot after this brief teaser
for the ending the show instantly throws
us into the life of a high schooler
named Sydney played by Sophia Lillis
Sydney lives in Pennsylvania and what
could be described as the height of
mediocrity due to the death of her dad
she lashes out and has anger issues this
anger begins to manifest in telekinetic
powers and the season centers around
Sydney learning to deal with these gifts
her mental health and life as a high
school student
Netflix seems to be picking from the
cast of it with Georgie featuring
lock-and-key recently and Beverly and
Stan heading this one up interestingly
the actor who plays Stan is also called
Stan in this show so yay
my brain doesn't have to do any extra
work don't think too much brain you'll
hurt yourself obviously all of the trio
are phenomenal actors and the two
definitely
a game - I am NOT okay with this
providing nuanced and grounded
performances that make them extremely
relatable
Sydney's powers tend to come to the
forefront whenever she gets enraged and
this can lead to nosebleeds stopping
taps from running and pulling signs of
their foundations all of the characters
are really like a bull and the slick
editing fast pacing and rockin
soundtrack make this series a blast to
get through I kind of feel like just
getting a playlist of these songs as
they really complete the style that the
show is going for and it's a fantastic
use of music the season itself also
clocks in at just seven episodes ranging
between 20 to 25 minutes often with
Netflix series I feel like they overstay
their welcome and drag things out to fit
in our runtime and I always find this
weird as Netflix shows don't have
commercials and the stream so they
really can be any length I am NOT okay
with this doesn't do that and because of
it it doesn't feel formulaic and I am
okay with this Sydney begins dating
Stanley but things become complicated
when she kisses a friend Dena after a
party struggling with her sexuality and
a rejection by Dena she runs off into
the night unleashing a powerful scream
that completely shakes her surroundings
Stan stumbles across this and slowly
becomes a mentor due to his knowledge of
comic books becomes a comic book in a
comic book story and they unearth the
rage that drives her abilities this
draws the eyes of another super-powered
being which from the brief glimpses that
we see is a man that can turn into smoke
now there isn't a big superhero showdown
at the show leads up to and actually for
the most part stays relatively
simplistic with the ending of the show
feeling more like the self the things
going ahead I'll talk about that in just
a bit
but I have to go over a couple of things
just before we discuss the ending during
this time she discovers that Dina's
boyfriend cheated on her and this causes
a lot of conflict at school
Dena finds out and Dinah's explains
Sidney for it and this plays into his
actions in the final episode slowly Sid
becomes more and more attracted to Dena
but it's initially an unrequited love
that adds a love triangle to the story
that ultimately leads to everyone ending
up
confused CID also an it's the truth
about her father who we learn was a
Marine SIDS father suffered from PTSD
and went through similar things to the
protagonist during an explosion on his
last tour he was left the sole survivor
and thus we can assume that he was the
cause of it similar to how Sid would
eventually caused the death of the prom
the guilt caused him to apparently
commit suicide but I'll get into my
theories on this and just a bit it all
comes to a head at the prom when Dena's
ex announces to the school that she's a
lesbian and just as he's about to reveal
his superpowers
she makes his head explode it's probably
the best moment of the season and it
brings everything up to speed with the
show finally ending up where it began
she flees to an outpost and is then
confronted by a stalker now to me this
is clearly her father and I think it's
safe to assume that he faked his own
death they did say in the season that he
never left a note and no not unheard of
it is uncommon for this in suicides and
I'm generalizing a lot there and people
do commit suicide without leaving things
behind but typically in TV shows they
just use notes for dramatic effect and
with this being absent here I do think
that it backs up the theory that he's
still alive if he didn't die then there
would be no reason to leave an out and
therefore we can guess that this is him
we know that during the huge event that
happened when he was in tour a giant gas
cloud came from it and as we know this
character can change into smoke there is
definitely a connection there between
the two
he's also been following Sidney and this
is probably because he was worried that
she may inherit his abilities and if she
did she would not know what to do with
them I definitely don't think that he's
a malevolent figure rather I believe
that he will be him and tor who will
help her to control her abilities so she
doesn't go off like he did clearly she
has the ability to kill and if left
unchecked this could lead to her
murdering many similar to how he did as
for Sidney herself though the police
seemed to be after her I don't think
that they would be able to tie her to
the death purely because she didn't
touch the character and there were
several witnesses around that saw this
there's no way to prove that someone
psychically killed someone so I do think
that she will definitely be in the clear
if they
is another season I believe that a
father will train her and slowly he will
come back into the picture which will
cause many problems in the family it
teases a lot for the future and I'm very
interested to see what happens next
now before we get into the review of the
season I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the Infinity
Saga box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to be and when the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the show in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of March in
the set will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize the best of luck to
everyone who takes part ok so I did have
a lot of fun with I'm not ok with this I
haven't read the graphic novels so I
didn't really know what to expect and I
went into this completely blind without
even seeing the trailer and just in
general didn't have any idea of what was
going on now since writing the script
for this video have went back and read
other reviews to see what people thought
about it and I was really surprised to
see that it didn't have that many
positive reviews on the country I have
seen pretty mediocre to negative ones
but I did enjoy it now whether this
changes are not after it releases
worldwide we're gonna see but I think it
deserves a lot of praise so feel Lillis
does a great job at dealing with the
main characters struggle and she
balances being unlikable at points when
the character lashes out to being very
charming and someone that you can easily
get behind it's quite a complex thing to
be able to do but the actor handles it
really really well in my opinion I think
that the soundtrack is phenomenal and
due to the seasons length it doesn't
overstay its welcome the show is edited
really well and because of it it's a
breeze to get through it worked for me
on a lot of levels and I found the humor
and characters in general to be nice
representations of high school life and
the complexities that come with it
though it's a pretty simple story and
comic book adaptations are a dime a
dozen right now I am NOT okay with this
was something that I had a lot of fun
with I would love to see more so the
series definitely did its job and that's
why I gets a 7 out of 10
okay so that's our review by now okay
with this obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on the season and whether you
enjoyed it or not comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please click the thumbs up button
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of this month's other big
Netflix release narcos Mexico season 2
which is gonna be linked at the end we
go over all of the ins and outs of the
show and talk about the real life story
behind it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below your access
to content early you can also suggest
video topics and breakdowns we massively
appreciate it and it goes a long way to
helping videos like this get made you
know come chat to us after the show
either follow us at definition whitey or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you